Shadow.
[Silence]
Continuing.
The chapter of patience
says says,
[Silence]
foram.
,
[Silence]
Here
mentions an narration on the authority
of Ibraim Abdahb,
a companion, the son of a companion.
He narrates that the messenger of Allah.
Wasam
and on the occasion of one of the days
during one of his battles in which he
met his enemies on the battlefield.
He says that the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam waited until the sun
until the sun crossed to the west.
meaning until the sun crossed the zenith
of the sky noon until it tended to the
west and then he stood and addressed his
companions. So why that particular time?
the prophet sallall.aii Wasallam
would often
initiate battles if it is up to him
after
right right away directly
or after
why because he's able to join the
prayers and this gives ample time to
make sure that the prayer is made and
then have plenty of time to deal with
the battle during sun while there is,
you know, still light out. if he
starts the battle before noon, there's
a fear of missing the prayer like
what happened during the battle of the
trench or the battle of the
confederates.
If he waits too long after
then there is fear of running out of
daylight. And so these are two very
necessary things for a battle. So the
prophet sallall.aii Wasam waited until
he then addressed his companions
most likely after having led them in
prayer just before leading them into
battle. He stood and he addressed his
companions.
This is something that is common not
just for the Muslim men, for most
most generals that just before the
battle is to ensue, just before go time,
he will give them a motivational speech,
remind everyone why they are there. And
so the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam said on this occasion, "Oh
people, do not wish to meet your enemies
in battle and ask Allah to pardon you of
such a burden. Yet if you do have to
meet them in battle, then be patient and
know, be certain that paradise is found
under the shade of swords."
And then he made dua sallam.
And this dua is categorized by the
scholars as being a dua that is made
when a person is to enter into battle or
to enter into
you know into
any kind of conflict with his enemy. He
said that which translates to Allah,
oh Allah, the one who has sent down the
book
and the one
who moves the clouds
and the one who has conquered all the
confederates.
conquer them on our behalf and give us
victory over our enemies. This narration
has been collected by both Bkari and
Muslim
subhanala
and